pas forcément comme vous devez imaginer
il y a des BG et puis il y a des gens
qui ont des études qui sont un peu plus
au dessus et bah on s'attend pas
forcément tant qu'on plonger tu choisis
parmi ces gens là
bonjour moi c'est lisandres j'ai 22 ans
je venais avec un six ou Sénart j'ai été
élu Mr France le 4 mars dernier et je
vis à Ajaccio encore ce n'est pas ils
étaient hôtesse de l'air et Stewart et
du coup bah ça m'a amené à changer
différentes fois de région j'ai vécu en
Bourgogne en Haute-Savoie et maintenant
bah c'est la Corse après j'ai fait des
études de STAPS donc d'où le fait que je
sois coach sportif mais aussi en
parallèle j'ai passé un diplôme de bpjf
de plongée et du coup je suis aussi
moniteur de plongée je me suis lancé
dans l'aventure Mr France pour pour
relever un défi personnel et pour
pouvoir m'ouvrir un peu plus parce que
de base je suis quelqu'un de réservé
j'ai connu Mister France par le biais
d'une photographe du comité Mister Corse
qui m'avait proposé il y a deux ans de
participer à cette élections mais je me
sentais pas encore prêt et dernière
durant le clip de kendji Girac j'ai
rencontré l'ancien Mister Corse qui
m'avait dit que j'avais une idée sympa
et que je pouvais potentiellement me
présenter au concours et du coup c'est
comme ça que ça a démarré et puis
surtout professeur était un peu dans le
milieu artistique et des choses comme ça
et un peu comédienne et du coup ça m'a
ça m'a encouragé dans ce milieu là dans
un premier temps il y a l'élection
régionale je me suis présenté parmi
d'autres candidats j'ai été élu Mr Corse
le 8 octobre dernier et donc j'ai pu me
présenter au concours Mr France les
critères de sélection pour un Mister
France maintenant c'est
ça a changé un peu avant la taille
c'était un mètre 78 maintenant c'est
passé un mètre 75 au niveau de l'âge
c'est entre 18 et 21 28 ans mais ça a
changé maintenant il va enfoncer la
limite à 30 ans bah forcément bon c'est
sûr faut avoir quand même un physique
avec relativement agréable on est
sélectionné pour représenter la région
au concours Mister France on a une
préparation parce que bon pour assurer
quand même un show sur une préparation
parce que je sais pas si vous avez dû
voir des images on a quand même fait les
danses des défilés et on a une semaine
de préparation au Cap Vert sur l'île de
Santiago à Praia et du coup bah on tous
ensemble les 29 élus pour pour
s'entraîner pour rassurer les spectacles
le jour J c'est pas vraiment une
compétition comme chez les miss parce
que nous le jour on sera tous rencontré
c'est plutôt un sentiment fraternel
d'amitié en fait même si on se
connaissait pas encore on essayait de
céder pour pouvoir avancer tous ensemble
c'était pas aspirer les écharpes passer
les cachets déchirer les vêtements
c'était plutôt attends c'est mamie je
vais te la remettre voilà c'est ce que
j'ai bien apprécié parce que moi le
concours Mister France je le faisais pas
pour gagner c'est surtout d'un point de
vue personnel pour me développer un
parce que en étant réservé je me suis
dit tout simplement je vais être au
contact en contact de la population donc
locale en Corse et ben maintenant ça va
être au niveau de la population
nationale et forcément quand on nous
parle on est un peu obligé de discuter
avec les gens et puis c'est quand même
avec grand plaisir que je me suis ouvert
et on n'est pas que la beauté incarnée
c'est aussi comme je vous ai dit des
prestations sur scène donc c'est un peu
savoir danser savoir se présenter on a
eu un QCM pour pour la culture générale
et du coup ça améliore un peu l'image
parce que souvent on nous voit comme
comme des hommes qui sont simplement
beaux alors qu'au final il y a autre
chose derrière physiquement on fait
d'être quand même prêt et puis c'est
bien de se sentir prêt parce que on
était bien près avant le concours on va
dire mais le fait de pouvoir s'entraîner
ensemble à faire du sport bah c'était
c'était assez convivial et c'est ça que
j'ai bien aimé certains qui étaient un
peu plus dans la compétition qui est
totalement compréhensible moi je n'étais
pas forcément alors mes parents au début
ils étaient pas au courant ils étaient
pas du tout au courant et d'ailleurs je
les ai agréablement surpris parce que
d'une personne réservée timide il
s'attendait pas que je participe à un
concours comme ça où je vais être
présenté devant des centaines de
personnes voir des milliers et bah ils
ont trouvé ça bien ensuite bah les
étapes c'était plutôt pendant la semaine
de préparation parce que bah le matin on
avait des entraînements en danse
l'après-midi on découvrait la ville de
Praia et c'est sa culture sa population
et ensuite après il y a une présélection
dans 12 sur les 12 élus régionaux pour
le jour J parce qu'elle doit forcément
noter 29 personnes c'est pas forcément
évident ça permet de rester en mettre le
nombre de personnes pour le jury c'est
29 12 et puis après bah il y a la remise
des écharpes avec donc la sympathie les
médias et puis les différents dauphins
et puis les pieds réduit sur France il y
avait quand même de la concurrence bah
forcément il y a comme vous devez
imaginer il y a des BG et puis il y a
des gens qui ont des études qui sont un
peu plus au dessus et bah on s'attend
pas forcément en tant qu'on est en
plongée tu as dit parmi ces gens là
alors j'ai gagné une montre qui est ici
j'ai gagné aussi des costumes des
sous-vêtements j'ai gagné des produits
de soins parce que quand même pour un
homme c'est bien d'avoir une belle peau
ce qui va arriver prochainement c'est il
y a les élections régionales donc c'est
à m'amené à voyager en France donc moi
je suis super content parce que ça me
permet de découvrir les différentes
régions parce que on part souvent à
l'étranger pour pour voir d'autres pays
mais la culture française je pense à mon
avis on a besoin de l'approfondir et moi
c'est ce qui va me plaire et puis on va
voyager aussi dans les DOM-TOM et ça je
trouve que c'est fantastique alors pour
l'instant le sport j'ai pas tellement eu
le temps et puis en plus avec la fatigue
parce que ça fait deux semaines que
qu'on n'arrête pas qu'on a pas un moment
pour nous puis dès que j'ai une minute
j'en profite pour dormir parce que le
truc c'est que j'ai enchaîné pas mal
d'interview pas mal de radio pas mal de
plateau TV et forcément au bout d'un
moment ça tire sur la corde journée type
bah je me réveille un petit déjeuner et
puis après il y a des parcs pour pour
les différentes activités on va dire
parce que il y a des il y a des journées
qui sont prévues plus ou moins pour la
médiatisation ça existe aussi à
différentes spectacles d'ailleurs qui me
permet d'être en contact avec certaines
personnalités et c'est vraiment très
sympa pour l'instant je peux pas
continuer à suivre mon travail parce que
bah je suis à Paris donc quand je le
retourne encore c'est je vais forcément
je vais essayer de reprendre un peu mon
rythme mais je sais que ça ensuite
reprendre la vie avec mais aussi quand
je vais rentrer je vais pouvoir
démarcher des associations
environnementales comme vous devez le
savoir c'est ma cause vous avez choisi
cette cause tout simplement parce que
venant du Niel je suis et puis en tant
que moniteur plongée je suis en contact
de la nature donc que ça soit sur les
plages mais aussi dans l'eau j'ai
constaté trop souvent qu'il y avait
beaucoup trop de déchets avant d'être
élu je vais essayer de manière
individuelle et là mon objectif ça va
être d'agir à travers des associations
et pouvoir avancer à plusieurs j'ai pas
un salaire fixe on va dire que ça va
être je vais être rémunéré plutôt sur
des prestations là par exemple ça peut
se retrouver sur des défilés sur des
footings ça peut se retrouver aussi sur
bah sur les élections régionales je vais
être rémunéré aussi après la suite je la
connais pas encore chaque chaque
déplacement chaque restaurant mais payé
pour le par le comité lorsque c'est dans
ce cadre là après chez moi forcément
c'est moi qui vais ça va heureusement
j'avais anticipé un peu et puis j'ai mis
un peu d'argent de côté
pendant ce temps là je vais je vais
continuer à travailler à côté forcément
parce que bah pour avoir un rythme de
vie plus agréable on va dire c'est mieux
d'avoir un peu plus d'argent ben moi je
vois comme ça après je pourrais très
bien et ne pas travailler moi
personnellement j'ai envie de me
développer dans le milieu du mannequinat
parce que je sais que j'ai plus ou moins
une tête intéressante j'aimerais bien
développer dans ce milieu là après c'est
sûr que je suis ouvert un peu à tout
quelqu'un cherche à prendre des
différentes expériences parce que
forcément c'est enregistre enrichissant
et j'essaie de devenir entre guillemets
la meilleure version de moi-même c'est
moi avant l'élection régionale en Corse
j'étais pas du tout insta loin de là et
bon d'ailleurs c'est un peu mon point
faible heureusement que je suis soutenu
par ma sœur sur ce point-là le concours
Miss France ça existe depuis une
centaine d'années et c'est commercialisé
nous ça fait à peu près 30 ans qu'on
existe bah c'est associatif donc
forcément bah ça explique les moyens
mais d'un autre côté je suis on sait sur
ça serait mieux d'avoir plus de budget
de cette modestie ça veut dire que ça
nous permet d'avoir d'avoir un peu
l'épis sur Terre on peut le retrouver
dans le concours dans le concours Miss
France et seront là comme comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure à se tréper de
chignon nous on est là à s'encourager et
à essayer de progresser tous ensemble je
sais qu'il y a quand même quelques
conflits je sais que quand même il y a
entre guillemets des liens qui se
tissent durant cette aventure en fait le
comité recherche quand même des beaux
physiques mais on peut voir différents
candidats qui avaient des physiques
plutôt atypiques et c'est justement là
où on retrouve cette richesse richesse
par la diversité dans dans ce milieu là
on peut pas vivre se projeter un an plus
tard parce qu'on sait pas ce qui va nous
arriver et c'est pour ça que moi le jour
j'aimerais bien intégrer le milieu du
mannequinat mais c'est sûr que si ça
n'arrive pas moi continuer ma vie de
moniteur plongée de coach sportif
franchement ça me va ça va